Well, it looks like
Hillary Clinton's e-mails
could be the subject
of more FBI probing.
Oh, my. Uh...
KASHER:
Great still for that.
-Yeah.
-(laughter) -Look at her.
-Mid probe.
-Mid probe. Mid probe.
First of all,
why does she have that face with
the headline "Weiner" above it?
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Oh, it's, uh...
It's FBI.
The federal beef injection.
-Uh, that's what it is.
-(laughter)
-And now...
-(applause)
Can we give you points?
-No, I don't... I can't get
points. -That's not allowed?
And now the hashtag
#HillaryForPrision is trending.
-Yes, with a typo. -(laughter)
-RICHARDSON: Of course.
In fact, it's been...
"Treading for 2 days"!
RICHARDSON:
Oh! No!
It is at the top of the treads.
-No!
-Treading for two entire days.
Say what you want
about Hillary's e-mails.
At least
they were spell-checked.
-(laughter) -This is
the biggest political typo
since 1948, when the newspapers
mistakenly reported,
"Dewey beats off Truman."
(laughter)
-(applause)
-Which is wrong.
Some people are claiming that
"prision" was spelled that way
on purpose
to avoid Twitter's censors.
These are the same people
that thought
"xHamster" was a medical pet
care Web site.
-(laughter)
-Hillary for "prision."
Comedians, what is "prision"?
-April.
-That's how you spell "prison."
-The dictionary is rigged!
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-Yeah, it is. Yeah.
-(applause)
It's not a typo at all.
That's Hillary's rap name.
-"Prision!"
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter, applause)
-Points.
It is musical.
Prision is a Vegas DJ
that gave my sister
a urinary tract infection.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
Sweet tats, though.
And she calls her
vagina "Hillary."
-She sure does.
-(laughter)